SELLERS ON THE SITE WHO
DON'T COLLECT SALES TAXES.
THE JUSTICES ARE EXPECTED TO
ISSUE A DECISION BY THE END
OF JUNE.
BRET?
>> Bret: GARRETT, THANK YOU.
THIS TAX FILING DAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
AMERICANS ARE WINNING
BECAUSE OF TAX REFORM.
FOR MORE ON THAT AND WHERE
WE ARE HEADED NEXT WE TURN
TO KEVIN BRADY CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE.
MR. CHAIRMAN, THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: GOT THE TAX LAW
DONE.
IT'S TAX DAY.
A YEAR BEFORE YOU SEE THE
CHANGES.
YOUR THOUGHTS AT HOW THIS IS
SHAPING UP AND, YOU KNOW,
THE CRITICISM THAT YOU ALL
TOOK FOR GETTING THIS
PASSED.
>> YEAH, SO, I HATE TAX DAY.
I THINK MOST FAMILIES DO.
THEY HATE TAX WEEK.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THIS IS THE
LAST TIME AMERICANS WILL
FILE THEIR TAXES UNDER THAT
OLD COMPLICATED UNFAIR TAX
CODE.
GOING FORWARD IT WILL NOT
JUST BE SIMPLER.
FAMILIES WILL KEEP MORE OF
WHAT THEY EARN.
MAIN STREET BUSINESS ALSO
KEEP MORE OF WHAT THEY EARN.
WE ARE REDESIGNED IT SO U.S.
COMPANIES CAN COMPETE AND
WIN ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
ESPECIALLY HERE AT HOME.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FROM IT.
FAMILIES NOW ARE ALREADY
SEEING HIGHER PAYCHECKS
BECAUSE THEIR TAX
WITHHOLDING HAS LOWERED.
SO INDIVIDUALS STOP AND
THANK US FOR THAT AND,
AGAIN, MAIN STREET OPTIMISM
IS AT 30 YEAR HIGH.
>> Bret: TODAY, YOU SAW
SPEAKER RYAN TALKING ABOUT
FULLY INTENDING TO MAKE THE
TAX CUTS PERMANENT.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> WE MADE THEM LONG TERM
FOR FAMILIES AND FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
BUT BECAUSE THE SENATE
RULES, WEREN'T ABLE TO MAKE
THEM PERMANENT.
WE THINK ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN PHASE 2 SHOULD
BE TO MAKE THEM PERMANENT.
BUT, MORE THAN THAT, WE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE IN WASHINGTON.
INSTEAD OF WAITING 30 YEARS,
AND FALLING FAR BEHIND OUR
COMPETITORS WORLDWIDE, WE
THINK WE OUGHT TO MOVE
AGGRESSIVELY EACH YEAR TO
MAKE AMERICA MORE
COMPETITIVE, TO MAKE
BUSINESSES MORE PRODUCTIVE,
TO ENCOURAGE MORE INNOVATION
AND WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO MAKE OUR TAX
CODE MORE FAMILY FRIENDLY.
YOU KNOW, JUST HELPING
FAMILIES STRETCH THEIR
BUDGETS FARTHER.
OUR GOAL IS EVERY YEAR TO
MAKE OUR TAX CODE AND OUR
COUNTRY STRONGER.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
STRETCHING BUDGETS.
YOU HAVE THE CBO OUT WITH
BUDGET DEFICIT PROJECTIONS.
AND YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
YEARS.
804 BILLION IN 2018.
AND IT TRICKLES UP OVER A
TRILLION DOLLARS AS YOU LOOK
DOWN TO 2028.
1.5 TRILLION.
I'M GOING TO PLAY A SOUND
BITE FROM A GUY YOU KNOW,
REPRESENTATIVE KEVIN BRADY.
>> EXCESSIVE FEDERAL
SPENDING IS OUR DISEASE.
LARGE FEDERAL BUDGET
DEFICITS AND ACCUMULATING
FEDERAL DEBT ARE SYMPTOMS OF
THIS DISEASE.
IF YOU CURE OUR SPENDING
DISEASE, THE SYMPTOMS WILL
VANISH.
IF YOU TREAT THE SYMPTOMS,
YOU MAY TEMPORARILY
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE PAIN.
BUT OVER TIME OUR ECONOMY
WILL CONTINUE TO WEAKEN.
OUR INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITIVENESS WILL ERODE
AND OUR CHILDREN WILL BECOME
THE FIRST GENERATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY THAT IS
POORER THAN THE PREVIOUS
GENERATION.
>> Bret: THAT WAS 2011.
STILL TRUE TODAY?
>> IT IS.
THE CBO REPORT, NOT REPORTED
BY VERY MANY IS THAT TAX
REVENUES IN AMERICA ACTUALLY
GREW AFTER TAX REFORM.
SO, IT'S THE SPENDING THAT
GREW FASTER.
SO, MY POINT IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A REVENUE
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE A SPENDING PROBLEM.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO
FOCUS OUR EFFORTS.
I'M CONVINCED WE COULD START
WITH THE RESCISSION PACKAGE
OF SAVINGS CUTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS PROPOSING
WORKING WITH CONGRESS.
SECONDLY, AND I THINK THIS
WOULD BE, I THINK, A MAJOR
SIGNAL TO AMERICA.
THE HOUSE HAS ALREADY PASSED
A BILL.
LAST YEAR WITH THE TRILLION
DOLLARS OF SAVINGS.
IN THE FIRST REFORMS OF
ENTITLEMENT MEDICAID IN ITS
HISTORY.
IT'S SITTING IN THE SENATE
TODAY, JUST A COUPLE VOTES
SHORT.
WE'RE GOING TO ENCOURAGE THE
SENATE TO MOVE ON THAT BILL
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT TAKES
A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF THE
SENATE.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL WAS ON WITH NEIL
CAVUTO TALKING ABOUT
RESCISSION EFFORT EARLIER.
>> THE PRESIDENT MEANWHILE
IS LOOKING AT 1.3
TRILLION-DOLLAR SPENDING
MEASURE.
WANTS TO RESCIND A LOT OF
THAT SPENDING.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH IT.
>> HE AGREED WITH IT HE WAS
INVOLVED IN THE NEGOTIATION
AND SIGNED THE BILL.
>> Neil: BUT HE WARNED I'M
NEVER GOING TO DO THIS
AGAIN.
>> WE HAD AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Neil: WERE YOU SURPRISED
BY WHAT HE SAID CAME OUT --
>> -- CAN'T MAKE AN
AGREEMENT ONE MONTH AND SAY
OKAY, WE REALLY DIDN'T MEAN
IT AND COME BACK THE NEXT
MONTH AND SAY OH, WE REALLY
DIDN'T MEAN OUR AGREEMENT.
>> Bret: THAT DOESN'T SOUND
VERY PROMISING ABOUT
RESCISSION POSSIBILITIES.
>> LOOK, BEFORE RECENT
HISTORY, RESCISSIONS WERE
PRETTY COMMON.
THEY HAPPENED MANY YEARS.
CONGRESS DIDN'T TAKE ALL OF
WHAT PRESIDENTS PROPOSED BUT
THEY TOOK SOME OF THEM.
I CAN'T THINK OF A MORE
IMPORTANT TIME FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
THIS MESSAGE TODAY, FOR
EXAMPLE, CONGRESS IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE FIRST
REDESIGN OF THE IRS IN TWO
DECADES.
REDESIGNING IT REFOCUSING IT
ON CUSTOMER SERVICE AND
REIGNING IN THE ABUSES OF IT
YOU KNOW, WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT TAX SAVINGS AND,
EXCUSE ME, ON SPENDING
SAVINGS.
I THINK, EVERY DAY.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK
ANYTHING ELSE BIG,
LEGISLATIVELY, IS GOING TO
HAPPEN BEFORE THE MID TERMS?
>> SO I THINK THE REDESIGN
AND REIGNING IN THE IRS IS
ONE THAT COULD GO TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US NOW THAT WE'RE ARMED WITH
ONE OF THE BEST TAX CODES ON
THE PLANET, WE NEED MORE
CUSTOMERS, SO I THINK A NEW
MODERN NAFTA BY THE END OF
THE YEAR I THINK IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
ECONOMY.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO MOVE ON
WORKFORCE.
LOOK, THERE IS ONLY TWO
THINGS HOLDING US BACK NOW
THAT WE HAVE A NEW TAX CODE.
WE NEED NEW CUSTOMERS AND WE
NEED MORE WORKERS.
THAT'S WHERE WE THINK THERE
ARE A LOT OF AMERICANS WHO
ARE TRAPPED ON THE SIDELINE
IN OUR WELFARE SYSTEM.
WE SHOULDN'T GIVE UP ON THEM
AND FRANKLY, THE COUNTRY
NEEDS THEM.
SO I THINK WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS THERE.
>> Bret: LAST THING.
AS YOU LOOK TO THE MID
TERMS, YOU ARE NOW AT 42
REPUBLICANS EITHER NOT
RUNNING, RETIRING.
CHARLIE DENT IS GETTING OUT
OF OFFICE BEFORE HE WAS
GOING TO FINISH UP HIS TERM.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS
NOT RUNNING AGAIN.
THAT'S AN UPHILL BATTLE FOR
HOLDING ONTO THE HOUSE.
>> IT IS AN UPHILL BATTLE.
IT IS HISTORICALLY AND IT IS
THIS TIME.
PEOPLE DON'T VOTE IN APRIL.
THEY VOTE IN NOVEMBER.
AND A LOT CAN HAPPEN BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN.
AND I THINK, AGAIN BACK HOME
I SEE A NEW OPTIMISM ON MAIN
STREET.
I SEE IT AMONG OUR WORKERS.
AND NOW WE ARE SEEING JOBS